non
où
à
[Musique]
non
à peine amri avait lui même
[Musique]
comment
qui
je suis plus
don pour mission de restaurer la paix sa
compagne et les phares d'ici mais ça
fait au mépris des cinq ans que la
population de béni et belleville est un
territoire est en deuil et il n'y a pas
une réaction
sa présence là bas de la monnaie d'un
pays sur le père congolais
on a des milliers de casques bleus et
malgré cela il m'a fait que ce qu'on est
parfois a vraiment des courses de
distance des casques bleus ou de l'armée
congolaise les autorités qu'on valait
tout comme les nations unies ont
l'obligation de résultats en ce qui
concerne la protection des civils donc
on ne peut pas continuer indéfiniment à
expliquer à la population qu'on ne
connaissez pas qu'il ya des problèmes de
coordination qui a des problèmes de
renseignement et c'est justifié
l'impuissance vis-à-vis de deux de ces
massacres
[Musique]